13.6 billion years ago.
The dark scaffold that supports all the
regular matter in the universe emerges ablaze
with stars.
But how did this stellar array evolve into a
structure littered with organized galaxies?
It seems they formed under constant threat
of destruction.
October 2020, astronomers discover a monster
lurking among the Cosmic Web's earliest
structures dating to 900 million years after
the Big Bang.
A supermassive black hole.
Six galaxies surround this cosmic giant
caught in its grip, seemingly linked to the
supermassive black hole by filaments of the
developing cosmic web.
It's like the universe has given supermassive
black holes an umbilical cord.
It's like an all you can eat buffet right
there.
Supermassive black holes are hungry beasts.
They feast on any matter that gets too close
to them.
Supermassive black holes are likely some of
the most powerful objects in the universe.
They can be anywhere between 100,000 to 10
billion times the mass of the sun.
Supermassive black holes have been a nemesis
for generations of scientists, not because of
their fearsome nature, but because nobody
knows how they grew so large so early.
I wish I knew where supermassive black holes
came from.
If I knew, I would have a Nobel Prize
hanging around my neck and I would wear it
every single day.
As someone who deeply loves supermassive
black holes, whose career is based on
studying supermassive black holes, it is
very frustrating to not know where they come
from.
Regular stellar black holes are the collapsed
cores of dead stars ranging from 3 to 10
solar masses.
But supermassive black holes, those are a
different beast.
13 billion years ago, not enough stars had
lived and died to build something as huge as
a supermassive black hole.
Now, the cosmic Web offers scientists clues
about the black hole conundrum.
We now know supermassive black holes grow
among the lattice of the young cosmic web,
gorging on the hydrogen gas that travels
along the filaments.
At the same time, when the cosmic web is
lighting up, supermassive black holes appear
to be stealing star fuel from the young
universe.
You might think that would kill a growing
galaxy.
And yet, most mature galaxies have a
supermassive black hole.
They really dominate the physics of what
happens in the centers of galaxies and even
how galaxies can evolve.
We think these galactic monsters have been
around from the start.
How, then, did the Web's young galaxies
develop around supermassive black holes?
The Milky Way's supermassive black hole is
called Sagittarius a star.
It's around 27 million miles wide and weighs
in at just over 4 million solar masses.
The environment around Sagittarius A-star is
very dynamic.
It can actually be a really hellish place.
There's this accretion disk that's full of
plasma is heated to thousands of degrees, so
you wouldn't necessarily think that that's a
great place for star formation to happen.
But that's exactly where astronomers decided
to look.
Using the Atacama Large Millimeter Array or
ALMA for short.
Scientists scanned the heart of the Milky
Way for dense cores of gas and dust stellar
embryos. They found more than 800 within
just 1000 light years of Sagittarius, a star,
including more than 40 embryos with
energetic jets blasting from their cores.
The telltale sign of the birth of stars.
It's really surprising to find those stars
there.
It's like hearing baby's cries from a wolf's
den.
It's not the place you would expect this to
happen, but in fact, stars are forming there
now. It's not as efficient as it is out here
in the suburbs where things are quieter.
But it works.
Baby stars igniting and thriving around a
supermassive black hole, the kind of hostile
environment we know existed in the young
Cosmic Web.
Starbirth is a key part of kickstarting
young galaxies.
This evidence suggests that star formation
is more resilient than researchers thought,
and they've developed a theory to explain
it.
Gas and dust race around the black hole in
the accretion disk heated to incredible
temperatures, plumes of gas break off and
blast into space.
The gas rapidly cools, collapses and forms
baby stars.
These accretion disks are the most chaotic
of stellar nurseries.
You see this mechanism that you think is
violently inhibiting star formation, and at
the same time, it's triggering the birth of
new stars.
Matter clumps at the cosmic webs
intersections feeding the supermassive black
holes around them.
Stars burst into life slowly building
galaxies.
This could be how our own Milky Way formed
among the filaments of the young cosmic web.
But new research suggests that growth in
these baby galaxies requires murder and
mayhem. And without them, we wouldn't exist.
The universe does need to churn things up.
You need to break some eggs.
To make an omelet, you need to introduce
some chaos into your galaxy to rapidly form
stars or grow black holes.
Smashing things together is how the universe
came to be.
The Hubble Space Telescope discovers many
distorted galaxies twisted, battered and torn
victims of violent collisions on a cosmic
scale.
Galaxies are never sitting quietly doing
nothing.
They're always undergoing change.
They're constantly encountering and slamming
into and colliding with and mixing with other
galaxies.
You can see images in Hubble of total car
wrecks of galaxies that are trying to merge
with each other.
We know that galaxies collide now.
But what about in the early universe when
the cosmic web was beginning to take shape?
Astronomers study a strange galaxy named
Himiko.
Born just 800 million years after the Big
Bang, three bright light sources suggest
intense star formation.
Detailed analysis reveals not one galaxy,
but three baby galaxies not yet fully formed.
Scientists call these youthful star systems
proto galaxies.
The trio that make up himiko are in mid
collision.
Computer simulations of the early universe
suggest Protogalaxies smashed together with
frightening regularity.
These violent shakeups trigger star birth.
Protogalaxies are rich in gas and when they
collide and merge, those gas clouds collide
and collapse and form stars, sometimes at
prodigious rates.
And after a billion years or so, all of that
structure forms and you get a formal galaxy.